and today's talk is about HTTP HTTP
headers I have two tips for any aspiring
speakers in the audience number one is
don't spill coffee on yourself before
you're going to deliver a talk at a
conference and secondly wear dark
clothing in case you spill coffee on
yourself before you give a talk at a
conference I'm happy to say I'm one for
two on those this morning so let's talk
about HTTP 1997 saw the standardization
of HTTP 1.1 which is the version that
most of us have been using for the last
20 years and it looks a bit like this
built into an HDTV exchange is metadata
both on the request and on the response
and it's pretty simple in HTTP 1.1 we
got the concept of the host header and
this was really important because for
the first time we were able to host more
than one website per IP address and in
the response there are only a few things
that are really important one is the
content type so we know what kind of
data we're going to be receiving and one
is the content length so we know how
much data we're going to be getting so
today that response looks a bit more
like this and hopefully some of these
headers are things that are new to you
that you don't recognize because we're
going to be talking about quite a few of
these today I'm interested in this for a
couple of reasons one is that I used to
be an elected member of the w3c
technical architecture group this is a
group of nine people who are like a
guidance body for the architecture of
the World Wide Web and we review
specifications and standards proposals
that standards bodies have that they
want to incorporate into the web
platform and I thought that this would
be JavaScript API s and new HTML
elements the surprising amount of the
time they were HTTP headers so these
were some of the headers that we
reviewed whilst I was on the tag the
other reason is that around this time
last year I was at a w3c conference in
in California and Steve Souders
is a well-known performance guru and
author of various books on web
performance cornered me and and we had
breakfast in this restaurant and he said
Andrew I wrote this blog post a few
years ago about invalidating scripts in
the browser cache so I want to serve a
long-lived script like an analytic
script or a star XI or something and I
want my end users to not continuously
have my server for this this object cuz
it's pretty static it's not changing but
I want to be able to update that script
without changing the URL and then have
every browser immediately request a new
version and he came up with this hack to
do this use his location dot reload and
and various kind of iframes and things
it's pretty it's pretty ugly and he said
this was a few years ago there must be a
better way of doing this now so I said
well surely Steve he must have heard of
the clear site data HTTP response header
you just attached this header to any
HTTP response from your origin include
the word cache and blows away everything
in the end users cache that's associated
with your origin and he said no I've
never heard of that that's amazing I
thought wow if Steve Souders has never
heard of this we probably haven't done a
good enough job of talking about these
new headers I should write a blog post
so I wrote a blog post and I looked at
all of the different techniques there
were for clearing the browser cache
including the one that Steve pioneered
and also various others like came up
with and the use of the clear site data
header and in doing so I realized that
it's actually not supported by any
browser which was a bit unfortunate it
is fortunately now supported by chrome
and I believe it's also coming very soon
in Firefox but I thought well what is
the state of the art for the other
headers you know what about all the
other things that we standardized a year
ago or two years ago or three years ago
what's the what's the uptake like how
are people adopting these things and
also headers that have kind of come and
gone and we shouldn't be using anymore
are they still hanging around so HTTP
archive is a project sponsored by fastly
Google and various other people it takes
the top 1 million websites and runs them
through web page tests every two weeks
that generates about 50 million HTTP
requests and the full HTTP request and
response exchange is then put into a
bigquery database and you anyone can
then query that database for anything
they want it's a really nice snapshot of
what the web looks like today and it's
updated every two weeks so I wrote some
SQL to look at those 50 million
responses so that's some in the region
of three or four hundred million HTTP
response headers and started to analyze
them started to rank you know what
headers are the most popular response
headers that we see in the HTTP archive
and starts to divide these into various
categories like headers that a best
practices that we should be using more
or you should be using better or maybe
already being used in a really good way
and also headers that we should be
seeing a lot less offer which are not
used correctly or are misunderstood so
let's start with those the headers that
we don't want and the first header in
this list that I didn't recognize one of
the most popular headers it was in the
top 20 P 3 P who knows what P 3 P is
show of hands
yeah not very many people well done for
those those who do its emitted by about
10% of websites in HTTP archive and most
curiously it's quite often set to the
phrase this is not a P 3 P policy which
makes you think you know is it a PPP
policy or is it not a PvP policy and the
back story here is that it's a standard
that was created in order to give web
sites an ability to declare a kind of
machine readable privacy policy and the
idea would be the user agents would
surface this information to the end user
in a way that it was consistent across
all the websites that you visit so you
can set your privacy preferences and
your user agent would be able to
you in an automated way if the website
was not compatible with those this seems
like a really good idea right it seems
like today this would be a great way for
us to comply with some of our GDP our
responsibilities and so on
unfortunately this was kind of ahead of
its time it was standardized in 2002 it
was only ever implemented by Internet
Explorer and interestingly Microsoft
implemented it in such a way that it
gated access to a small piece of browser
functionality that people wanted to use
now because the value was never surfaced
in the UI anywhere didn't actually
matter what you set the value to it
wasn't validated so this is not a PTP
policy would pass that check needless to
say please don't use this header it's a
bit of Internet trivia and it's kind of
an indicative of the messy way in which
the web evolves so to go from that which
is pretty niche to something which
probably everyone in the room is
familiar with the expires header one of
the most popular headers in the database
present on almost 80% of HTTP responses
the expires had a set to date at which
the content should be considered stale
in cache this is pretty simple it's
interoperable it's supported pretty
consistently by all browsers the
question in my mind though is why is it
always Thursday the first - December
1994 at 4:00 p.m. GMT overwhelmingly
this is the most popular value by a very
very long way why
anybody can hazard a guess there's no
default value for a TCP header but it is
the example in this back
why would you copy and paste the exam
from the spec so I have a couple of
theories about this one is that almost
uniquely for a standardized date format
the HTTP date format includes the day of
the week
so if you think of some arbitrary date
in the past in your head in order to
form an HTTP day you need to know what
day of the week that was and you just
often can't do that you know if I think
of like 1st of January 2000 for example
I don't know what day of the week that
was so I can't do that easily the second
thing is that it seems like people feel
like a date that's just a little bit in
the past is not in the past enough so
commonly these dates are very long a
very long time ago so you know they're
in the early 90s before HTTP was even
standardized so you know FYI a date
that's two hours ago is fine it's just
as in the past as a day that's twenty
years ago and if you do copy the example
from the spec which is also fine you
should see this
next to it which says if a response
includes a cache control field with a
max age directive a recipient must
ignore the expires field there's a
little bit of spec language here but by
Byfield we mean header and by recipient
we mean browser so if you include an
expires sorry if you include a cache
control header in your response then you
don't also need an expires header that's
what it's telling you so it's impossible
to ignore this look it's right there
it's right underneath the example that
you copied and pasted it from the spec
so it seems very unlikely that anyone
would include both of these headers in
the same response except obviously 64
percent D so that's a lot of wasted
bytes of expires headers which are being
overridden by a cache control header
that's part of the same response so by
all means he's expires as an indicator
of freshness but you do not need to use
an expires header and a cache control
header in the same response and quite
commonly I see this kind of thing
another person who wrote this is really
really insistent that this response not
be cached
so much so that we have an expires
header in the past using the correct
date we have a cache control header
listing every single possible cache
control directive including summer and
not standards and we have a pragma
header which is not actually a response
header at all or if pragma was
standardized as a request header so if
you want something to not be cached this
is absolutely fine unless you are
dealing with some kind of really crazy
HTTP client that really doesn't
understand HTTP properly now let's move
on to another header X cache this header
is is kind of a representative of a
large number of headers which don't
exist there's no link on this slide to a
spec because there is no spec there is
no document there's nothing that's held
anyone what this header is and yet it's
on 13% of the responses in HTTP archive
that's quite curious also it's curious
that everybody seems to agree on what it
is because it's almost always set to the
word hit and admittedly this is our
fault or at least it's it's largely the
CDN industry's fault because when
responses come through CD ends like
firstly we will add debug headers like X
cache to tell our customers whether
these responses were served from our
cache or whether we had to fetch the
resource from their upstream servers and
we really probably shouldn't be doing
this it's in good company there are over
a million headers in HTTP archive which
don't mean anything they are not
interpreted by the browser they're not
used in any way for end-users unless you
have some kind of browser extension that
is specifically looking for one of these
headers he's not doing anything to
change your internet experience so these
are just a waste of bytes on the wire
and of course 99.99 plus percent of
people consuming your web content are
not your own development team so in the
case where some of these headers are
useful for debugging purposes you could
write some code like this on your edge
network or on your edge router well like
whatever is the the sort of front most
part of your architecture to strip off
headers which are not functional
now another one that I used to use
myself before I did this research was
x-frame options the purpose of this
header is simply to prevent your site
being included in another site in an
iframe why would you want to do this
well it's possible to make an iframe
completely transparent and so the
practice of doing this loading a foreign
site into an iframe making it
transparent and then convincing a user
somehow to click on a specific spot on
that page is known as clickjacking
and this was used to be very popular for
people to generate Facebook Likes and
that kind of thing so using this header
we can prevent our site being framed by
another site it's extremely popular it
works pretty well and it's pretty simple
the only thing wrong with it is just
there's a slightly better way of doing
it and they discovered there's a there's
a content security policy directive
called frame Ancestors and this allows
us to control more precisely how and
whether our site can be framed by
another origin the benefits to this are
number one you already have a content
security policy so it's one fewer
headers and secondly a content security
policy is a better spec it's better
written it has better interoperability
so you can expect a more consistent
behavior in edge cases than you would
with X frame options and finally let's
mention via now wire is uniquely amongst
the headers I'm talking you I've talked
about so far both a request and a
response header and it is added by
intermediaries through which your
request or response passes so imagine
you have fastly or some other CDN or you
have your own caching layer in front of
your micro-services architecture at the
backend or maybe your end user is in a
university or an institution that's
funneling all its outbound web traffic
through a proxy all of these situations
will result in a via a DAT being added
to the request and then when the
response comes back from the server a
via header will be added to the response
as it passes back through those same
layers now the via request header is
actually very important because each of
these layers is essentially terminating
an HTTP request and they make a new one
to the neck
first layer in the chain so we need to
make sure that all of these layers speak
the same version of HTTP and that's the
that's the first job of the via header
the second job is to prevent loops so
let's imagine you have to see DNS and
they are both configured to treat the
other one as their back-end so if they
don't have a mechanism for detecting
that they've already seen this request
before and in fact they have it kind of
as a live connection then in theory they
could continually connect to each other
until they run out of sockets so the via
header prevents this by telling you that
a request has already gone through you
so you can you can refuse to forward it
again but the response header is
informational this is just a header
that's added on there way back down the
chain and ultimately it tells the
browser which proxy to process this
response it doesn't do anything with
that information so it becomes a little
bit like an X cache header which you
don't really need so now we've done some
cleanup let's talk about best practices
what should our HTTP responses look like
and the first and most important thing I
need to talk to you about is content
security policy I was a bit glib earlier
when I said obviously you've already got
a concert security policy because
statistically the likelihood is that you
don't although I'm sure in this room the
the the statistics and more than three
percent but that's pretty bad and the
reason for this is I think that a
content security policy is hard it's
hard to implement the average length of
policies that I saw in the archive was
six hundred bytes it's one of the
longest headers that you commonly see
conceptually it's very simple you just
provide a list of origins that your page
is permitted to make connections to in
order to load resources you can
subdivide this by types of resources you
can say these origins for script these
origins for images and so on or you can
just have one set of origins for all
kinds of resource lights this creates a
kind of a firewall in the browser so you
load the page which is the first arrow
at the top and then once you've got the
page you then have an execution
environment that is subject to
essentially a firewall defined
by your content security policy this
means that if you have some
vulnerability that allows an attacker to
execute script on your page there's a
limited amount of stuff they can do with
it they couldn't for example load a
larger payload to further attack the
page and they couldn't exfiltrated Atta
from the page to their own origin and of
course there may be other ways they can
do this but this is one defense against
that the problem is things like this so
this is a small part of the largest
continuity policy that I found in HTTP
archive it's 10k this is prefixed to
every single response this server is
generating and it includes some really
awesome little nuggets like it includes
unsafe inline which allows any script to
be executed within the the response body
of the HTML itself it includes unsafe
eval so we can we can construct scripts
dynamically and avowal them within the
page it includes domains like cloud
front on that which anyone can serve
content on please tag manager anyone can
sign up for a tag manager account and
I'll place the scripts which is served
on that host name and my personal
favorite is its white listing starred
Amazon AWS com so you may as well write
you know X debug colon and then 10k of
underscores before every response and it
would be as effective as this content
security policy so by all means use
content security policy in fact
definitely use content security policy
but think about it in terms of the
security benefits that you're getting
from it not what you have to write in it
in order to do what you need what you
want to do because you will end up with
a CSP that's essentially offering you no
protection at all so another security
header that's very important is strict
Transport Security how many times do you
think people go to your website and type
HTTP colon slash slash and then your
domain name basically no one ever does
that and yet hopefully your site
is not available over HTTP you're only
serving on HTTPS so there are a lot of
occasions when somebody will hit your
site on unencrypted HTTP and you'll
redirect them to the HTTPS version so
the purpose of this header is simply to
prevent that from happening as soon as a
an end-user sees this header on any
response from your origin any future
connection to your site even if it
appears that the user wants to connect
over HTTP will be made over HTTPS anyway
and the browser will then present the
URL to the user as https without having
to do a redirect this is actually a very
aggressive header you can use it with
the preload directive and that will
enable browsers to socialize that
information to all other instances of
the browser so in theory one single
chrome user coming across your strict
Transport Security header will then make
every single other user of the Chrome
for that the Chrome browser connect to
your site
only over TLS so it can be extremely
aggressive it can also be pretty
devastating if your TLS is not set up
correctly but if it is and once you're
happy then adding includes subdomains
and preload to this head I will offer
you a lot of security now moving from
security to privacy the referrer policy
header is another thing that depresses
me because it's really not adopted as
widely as I think it should be and I
think this one is particularly
interesting in light of the fact that
we're all under a lot of pressure to
comply with regulatory requirements
around user privacy but those those
regulatory requirements tend to distract
us and they tend to be around the
specific things that are subject to
regulation and not the things that maybe
are of equal concern to end-users but
just aren't subject to specific rules so
referral policy prevents the
exfiltration of data that is contained
within URLs so if you link from your
page to some third-party and that link
sits on a page that has a query string
that contains some kind of user inputted
information then that information will
be in
cluded in the request the third party
when the user clicks the link so let's
say I'm on your search page I've
searched for something my search query
will potentially be leaked to the site
that you're linking team so referral
policy is a way of limiting the amount
of information that's shared my
preference is the origin when cross
origin option which allows the full URL
to be included in the referral header
when linking within your origin and it
will just include the bare origin when
linking to a foreign origin now there's
a whole suite of response headers that
start with access control these are part
of a feature called cross-origin
resource sharing or cause these headers
unlike the others that I've mentioned so
far our permissive headers so adding
them to your site makes your site less
secure rather than more secure the most
secure way of deploying cause is not to
deploy at all but of course being able
to interact with foreign origins is
sometimes very useful so it is a useful
feature that is popularly used one of
the most important things about cause is
that it makes responses specific not to
the server omitting the response but to
the origin of the page making the
request so if I request a resource from
a page that was served by origin a dolly
example com2 well let's say requesting
origin died example.com as it says in
the slide to foreign origin com then
foreign origin com needs to generate a
response that cites the name of the the
origin making the request that means
it's very difficult for us to cache that
response and serve it to anyone that
wants it in fact in theory we could
serve completely different responses to
different origins that were making the
request which kind of makes you feel a
bit uncomfortable about this as a part
of web architecture because it means
that the URL is no longer solely the
only piece of address information for a
piece of content in fact this has been
something that was very controversial
while I was on the tag particularly
around the idea of credentials so one of
the things that you choose when you're
making a cross-origin request for a page
is whether to send credentials ie do
send the cookies that are associated
with the origin you're sending the
request to if you choose to do this then
the server that you're sending the
cookies to has to acknowledge that it
needed them by replying with an access
control allow credentials true response
header if it doesn't do that or it sets
that head of value to false then the
browser will not let you see the
response that you've received even if
the response is a valid response and
also it will look like a network error
rather than telling you exactly what the
error was so you just have to guess and
resubmit the request without credentials
or the other way around so I I don't
know what the solutions is problem is
but it's quite an interesting indication
that headers start to become not just
metadata but part of the identity of the
object itself if you're interested in
just getting a very quick health check
on the state of your site's headers
security headers to i/o is a pretty good
place to go for this it will give you a
basic kind of grade and advice on how to
improve your site's headers nothing to
do with me or parsley but it I find it
quite useful tool Mozilla also have a
tool called observatory which
essentially does the same thing either
one of those is a good place to go to
start now let's go from security and
privacy to performance who here has
heard of client hints so client hints is
a mechanism for requesting that the
browser send you additional information
about the users about the users
environment about their device and about
their browser and potentially about
their personal preferences and we can
request this using this except CH header
now the currently standardized client
hints include the device pixel ratio if
the primary display or the display on
which the browser is currently in focus
the width of the screen and the width of
the viewport and also a boolean telling
you whether the user has enabled data
saving mode in their browser we can also
send a lifetime header that tells the
browser how long we want to receive that
information for without having to
continually request it so on subsequent
requests after we've emitted these
headers the browser will then send us
the information we
asked for the width of the screen
viewport width the device pixel ratio
and whether the safe data is enabled and
this client hints this designs a
framework so many other of these client
hints might be adding in the future to
give us additional context for what kind
of device and what kind of environment
the user is operating in the problem
that I have with client hints is they're
not sent in the first request you have
to ask for them and as a server you are
not in a position to make a request to
the client you can only send it
information in a response so when the
browser makes that first request for the
page you don't get any client hints you
can ask for the client hints in the
response and then you will get those
client hints for all of the sub resource
requests that are made from that page so
you'll get the client hints for the
images the scripts the style sheets the
fonts and everything but you can't use
that information when you're generating
the HTML page itself so I'm worried that
this will be an incentive for developers
to make that first response or redirect
back to the same URL with an except CH
header so that we then get a request
with the client hints especially for
things like save data because in theory
settings save data one could prompt you
to completely change the HTML that you
send the user like CNN for example has a
very very big default response but they
also have seen and light which is a very
very smaller a very much smaller payload
there are many new client hints that are
being posed this is a proposal from my
quest at Google to rethink the user
agent header which is probably a good
idea so instead of the browser
identifying itself as Mozilla followed
by a string containing the names of
almost all of its competitors you will
have a series of headers that divide
these region into a number of discrete
tokens so for example the UA will just
be the primary identifier for that
browser and the major version platform
architecture engine also things like
accept language I think we've concluded
over time that except language is
complicated format there's too much
fragmentation within the way that that
browsers format an accept language
straight there are too many different
ways of coming up to the forming that
essentially the same except language
result so a client hint could make
accept language far more casual would
creating a new mechanism for browsers to
identify themselves just essentially
lead us to the same problem again like
browsers will just lie in the new
mechanism and then will create another
new mechanism that will try and prevent
them lying again I don't know but I
think the the reset button is overdue
and pushing the reset button on user
agent is probably a good idea now the
link header was standardized with HTTP
it's a very very old header and it was
designed to provide semantic relations
between resources so you can be looking
at a resource say a chapter of a book
and the link headers can give you
relations to other resources like the
previous chapter the next chapter the
index that kind of thing now we don't
really use the web like that anymore
but the link header is still generically
useful for linking together resources
that are semantically related and the
most popular use of this header today is
preload which is to say this other
resource is going to be needed in order
to render this page so please load it as
soon as possible you do it like this
it's commonly used for fonts because
fonts can be discovered very late in the
process of loading a document you need
to scan the page discover the style
sheets load the stylesheet then discover
the font declaration
so you still possibly don't load the
font at that point because you need to
know whether the font is being used
somewhere on the page so fonts can
actually be kicked off very late in the
waterfall if you want them to be loaded
a lot earlier then link preload is a
good way of doing that this is a this is
from a case study by audios Marnie at
Google that shows how adding link
preload affects the tinder website and
you can see that
we start with some of their JavaScript
loading at around the one-second mark
and I'm talking there about when we
start to load the JavaScript not when
it's finished after we add the preload
tags all the JavaScript starts to load
at the same time around the 200
millisecond mark so we can substantially
increase the speed at which we get to a
useable interactive site by using
preload the problem is that we have to
wait until the server sends a status
code before we can send headers so
preload substantially improves the
performance we can start to load our
fonts a lot earlier but we still can't
load them as early as we'd like to and
here's an illustration of why so when I
type in a web address and press Enter
the first thing the browser does is it
makes DNS lookup for that hostname then
it negotiates a tcp + TLS connection
then it sends the request then it waits
for the server to think and the server
is going to be doing some database
access and authentication templating
maybe reaching out some other micro
services assembling a response and
ultimately the server will decide this
is a 404 all this is a 200 or whatever
the H the correct HTTP response code is
and then once it's decided that it can
then emit a header block and then it can
start streaming the response which it
might still be building so we already
support the idea of built of streaming
responses but we have to wait for that
status line before we start to do that
so firstly we're working on the new spec
which we call early hints this will be a
new HTTP status code and the description
of this status code is basically - no
yet so you would omit this status code
very quickly after receiving the request
before you've done any server-side
processing and it would give you the
opportunity to send some headers and
most notably it would give you the
opportunity to send link preload headers
then the browser can start loading those
critical resources before we've decided
whether this is going to be a 200 or not
so now the waterfall can look like this
we can start loading those
resources whilst the server is still
considering the the original request and
we haven't yet received the first bytes
of the response now also within
performance we have measurement related
headers any performance engineer will
tell you that sort of 50% of the
challenge of performance is measurement
and one of the the best additions to the
platform in this area has been the
server timing header so server timing
allows us to start exposing some of
what's going on during that server think
time which we are addressing with the
early hints status code we can start to
try to reduce the amount of server think
time by understanding where we are
spending that time are we spending in
the database are we spending it in
memcache are we spending that that in
you know HTTP requests to other servers
this is the syntax it's quite flexible
you can attach a millisecond timestamp
to a label or you can just omit a label
or you can omit a label on a description
in Chrome this data actually gets
rendered as part of the timing panel of
dev tools this the only browser
currently to visualize server timing and
it's pretty rudimentary one of the
limitations of server tiny is that
there's no order information so you can
see that although we have a waterfall in
the the main data here for server timing
data it's all just stacked up on the
right that's because there's no
information within server timing that
tells us that this happened before this
or this blocks that part of the reason
for this is that server timing is
expected to be generated across multiple
pieces of physical infrastructure with
different clocks so it would be
ineffective solution to include
timestamps
we could add some kind of mechanism for
saying this before that or this blocks
that or something like that and
hopefully that will be in a later
remission of this spec what's really
interesting to me about server timing is
that it has a JavaScript API so within
the page we can actually get access to
the data that we're sending and then you
can beacon that data back to some
collection server or aggregation server
and
actually this is one of the first
instances where we have a JavaScript API
into the data that we're receiving in
our HTTP response headers most of the
time it within the page when the jobs
could be run on the page we can't really
see the data that is in the HTTP header
section really the only other instance
is cookies but cookies have side-effects
they they you know they have a
client-side state so what if we were to
use this to just send arbitrary data to
the browser this is really useful for a
lot of reasons one reason is that many
large sites will generate relatively
static pages and then save them in an
edge cache or you know some kind of
cache that is is very hot and close to
the end user for the performance but
they want to enhance these pages with a
little bit of extra data which
personalizes them something like the
number of number of pages left on your
pay wolf on your pay wall credit for
example so imagine that you could add
headers to the response to add that
extra information and then you could use
JavaScript to reassemble it now I'm not
saying this is a good idea it's
definitely a misuse of the header but
it's interesting that this is this is
currently the only header would actually
let you do this I want to finish with
mentioning a couple of headers which
don't really exist and use it will form
yet feature policy is shipped in Chrome
in fact chrome is kind of racing ahead
of the rest of the web on this one of
the problems that we have with a web
that is now 30 years old is that it's
big the platform is huge and so the
attack surface is huge the range of API
is you can inadvertently trigger as huge
and some of the features that it exposes
are really powerful
so wouldn't it be great if we could
selectively turn off bits of the web
platform that we know we're not going to
use either because we just want to avoid
any potential vulnerabilities that might
exist in those API s or because we want
to self-police we know that we have a
large development team
and we don't want anyone to to use a
feature that we've decided we don't want
to use let's say for example you've
decided in a matter of policy that your
website will not also play video on page
load that's something you'd have to
police with code reviews and so on or
you could write a feature policy that
just says autoplay not so now the
ability to autoplay video does not exist
on the web
within this page this is really powerful
I love this feature and it's a framework
like client hints so we can add more and
more policies as the best practice or
what we consider to be best practice on
the web evolves as of today there are 10
reasonably well agreed policies which
are listed on left here and you'll see
these if you go to mdn and search for
feature policy but like I said chrome is
kind of racing ahead and if you actually
go into Chrome Canary enabled
experimental web features and query for
the allowed features they actually
shipped quite a lot of additional
features which have not yet really been
discussed in great detail in the
standards community but some of these
are great ideas like document right for
example though so if you set document
right none then document right doesn't
exist as an API on your page that's for
you and also for any third parties you
log into the page and you know I recall
in a previous job we had all sorts of
trouble trying to get advertisers to
stop using document or write as a
mechanism to add their content to the
page this would be a very simple way of
solving that problem instantly so I'm
very excited about this I'm less excited
about the fact that this is going to
turn into a bit of a content security
policy problem this is currently the
tightest feature policy you could set
and as more and more policies are added
this would just get longer so hopefully
at some point there will be some
consolidation and you'll be able to
reference a policy like you know best
practice web 2019 or something and that
will aggregate quite a lot of these
policies together the Google amp team
have specifically highlighted feature
policy as one of the things that they
need in order to move amp from
being a proprietary solution to one that
standards-based and the final thing is
origin policy and I'm bit sad about
origin policy it was it's been proposed
for over a year and just doesn't seem to
be getting very much interest but the
idea of origin policy is to take you
know this this situation where we had
this really clean response and this
became this really long and messy
response to take this and get back to
that simple response again because if
you think about all the headers that
we've talked about today very few of
them actually relate to the specific
response we're about to receive so
something like strict Transport Security
for example is manifestly an origin
level setting because it doesn't matter
which response I attach it to it will
apply from then on to my entire origin
some things are theoretically response
specific like content security policy or
referrer policy but in practice no one
really has a different content security
policy for every page they have one for
their whole site so it makes sense to
take a lot of this stuff and move it out
of individual HTTP responses and into
something which maybe we might call an
origin policy and it could be a JSON
file that we store at a well-known
location and just reference in every
HTTP response so we can separate the
stuff which is common across all
responses from the stuff which is
specific to this response now the
reality is this doesn't actually improve
performance very much if at all because
with HTTP two we now have header
compression and the header compression
dictionary is connection level so when
we make a second response if we include
the same headers that we included on the
first response then the size will be
basically zero because the connect the
the connection already has a compression
dictionary that contains that content so
it's not going to improve performance
very much but it does improve developer
experience because you're able to
segregate the headers which are origin
specific from those which are response
specific so I've covered a lot of
headers today this is kind of a little
cheat sheet for
to take home and think about the the top
left ones are ones that you know apart
from future policy are ones which if you
don't have for them already you probably
should there are very few use cases that
don't call for CSP or strict Transport
Security or refer a policy or link
preload at the same time in the bottom
right if you're still serving any of
these headers maybe think about whether
you whether you really still need those
if you want more detail on any of this
or indeed more headers because I really
have only covered a very few of them
then this blog post is a good place to
start this is the ones that I would like
to see less of and there's a link at the
bottom of this to a sec as a part two
where we cover the the ones the good
ones and you can fetch you can get the
slides from my SlideShare account and
that's it thank you
do we have I guess if you have questions
feel free to come and talk to me